june has long been earmarked as the
month for moving on
now it's not moving so quickly not in
parts of scotland due to have
restrictions reduced next week
not until the day of zero deaths is
every day
some areas north of the border will step
down on schedule
from level two to one but places like
edinburgh will not
nicola sturgeon called it a slight
slowing down
in areas where cases are relatively high
or rising
our judgment is that a slight slowing
down of the easing of restrictions
to allow time for more people to be
fully vaccinated
will help protect that progress overall
the hollywood announcement eased glasgow
onto level two restrictions
the city having been stuck on level
three the pause in progress
will affect millions across scotland
i think it's a good idea you're better
to be safe than sorry
i think that it's a cautious approach is
a sensible approach but
um yeah the quicker we get vaccinated
and
back to normal obviously the better the
holyrood roadmap out of restrictions
isn't one drawn in straight lines nicola
sturgeon said
she had had to adapt to changing
circumstances
and a changing impact of the pandemic it
would be wrong she said
to ignore warnings from scientists of a
third way
it is a politician's response to the
scientists up north
what now down south june the 21st is the
proposed date for england
lifting all restrictions but the same
scientists
issue similar warnings and calls for
delay
we have a new virus with new
characteristics in a situation that's
never really been replicated anywhere in
the world
and uh and the adversary is a virus that
has
exceeded all expectations in its ability
to mutate to
generate new mutations to to to make
itself fitter and faster
and to avoid some of our immunity so so
this is not something
that we should be underestimating the
vaccination effort is a key element in
decision
making so two case numbers tuesday was
the first day since the pandemic began
that the uk reported zero deaths
although there can be delays in
reporting
on a bank holiday weekend there are
encouraging
signs but still with uncertainty and
continued fears
of pressure on the nhs if you look at
previous lockdowns
it's really been pretty clear they were
the only means of preventing
nhs overwhelm so as far as we're
concerned they were pretty
open and shut cases i think it's much
more finely balanced this time
downing street says the prime minister
hasn't seen anything in the data to
delay a lockdown exit
his decision when it comes will balance
public safety
and expectation the way the cases are
going down at the moment and
the way it's been a steady pace i think
it's good
because rather than just lifting
everything in april they've waited
and i think it's working pretty well i'm
trying not to worry about anything
yeah you know i'm just trying to enjoy
the sun and i'm trying not to
worry about anything else at the moment
because it's just been going on for too
long
edinburgh having reached its june day
conclusion
it's now london's turn a decision about
the 21st
is due the week before it will be a
tough call
risking as it does tough consequences
james matthews sky news edinburgh